- I definitely forgot that she snorted.
I was like ohh! (chuckles)
(melodious music)
I was 12 years old when I met her.
- We talked for maybe two
or three hours, over A-I-M,
when he asked me to be
his girlfriend. (laughs)
- I used to get off at 1:40
and go visit her at school.
- I thought I was a big nerd.
He seemed like a really
cool skater boy. (laughs)
It was Danny's first kiss!
- We-we went under the air
hockey table and it happened.
- I felt, great.
I really liked Danny.
- Like the puppy love, kind of thing.
- Danny and I broke up because
he liked another girl and I could tell.
- I feel bad about the breakup because
a week after I broke up, I
got with my next girlfriend.
- I guess today, I'm pretty nervous.
But I also think it's just a kiss.
- Reenacting a first kiss, that's weird.
- He's like laughing already, right?
This how you thought you'd
see me again? (laughs)
Can you fit?
You're too big.
What's this?
- It's a tattoo.
(laughs and snorts)
- I have gla-- (laughs)
Can I take off my glasses?
- [Maia] Yes.
Why were we underneath the table?
- I don't know, you took me there.
- No, you went under first.
Probably, I have no idea.
I don't remember.
- You did everything.
- I did everything? (chuckles)
- You took my innocence.
- We have to kiss soon I think.
- I know!
- Come here darling.
You look scared, don't look scared.
Wait, this is how it was.
- [Danny] I don't remember...
- This must have been how
- [Maia] it was.
- You just like did it.
- Did I really?
(both laugh)
- Please, please, just come here.
(stammers)
- Okay.
- [Danny] Three, two...
- There we did it.
- Oh my God.
- It was just a kiss, right?
What?
- Yeah, I know. I know, it was.
Yeah, it was just a kiss.
(laughs)
I don't know.
It feels...
- When was the last time you saw me?
- Like two years ago.
We hung out but we didn't kiss.
- I said you were cool.
I forgot you were also shy. (laughs)
- Is that what you told them?
(both laugh)
- He's a really cool guy.
- Can we hang out again ever?
- Yeah.
- [Maia] Yeah.
- It's not weird, hanging out with you.
- Yeah, it's not weird.
- Hi.
- [Maia] Hi!
Now we're...(laughs)
Okay, we can hug.
- She's always been like a goofball.
- Feeling old jokes pop up in my head.
Just by seeing him, that
was like the most fun part.
- I guess we've kind of
grown with each other.
- Yeah, I missed Danny.
Not too much in a couple way.
- Well, I missed her as a friend.
Yeah, she was cool.
Everytime we meet up, it's kind
of like I saw her yesterday
or something.
- It did feel like a lot
like a best friendship.
I think that kind of has followed me
in relationships I've
had since being younger.
Maybe Danny started that a little bit.
- It was cool, it was fun.
I'd do it again. (laughs)